soit très beaux jours kosslick ça valait
bien on est formé de ce chroniqueur
numérique
on vient de battre la diversité sur
toutes les autres chaînes comme c'est
vrai que là les trois sur le même
plateau
c'est beaucoup franchement ça fait
plaisir
des messages cyril bientôt aussi
oui absolument les doigts c'est quoi
c'est faux dit je fais ma chronique
tranquille comme ça je rentre chez moi
je mets s'est vite et j'entends ça pour
nous raconter votre casting ben posséder
c'est complètement faux pas contre mon
cas c'est complètement fou en fait c'est
un premier casting c'est pas le location
bouge et où j'ai fait les anges csv
d'avant d'accord où j'ai 18 ans d'accord
mais je suis employé est en fait je suis
dans mon casting ou chaud train
d'expliquer en fait aux producteurs que
je suis donc vraiment c'est le contexte
et quelle est ta viande selon moi je dis
barachois employés ne pourra envoyer bah
voila j'ai pas mes parents inquiets tu
veux faire quoi
j'aimerais bien revenir blogueuse et
sinon tu te rentre souvent des trucs non
cyrille barrette l'émission tourne chez
soi merci à demain est ce que tu te
rendes des trucs c'est là où on voit que
les candidats ils sont un peu naïf
casting hautement titude rendent les
trucs normalement tu dois dire je vais
faire le casting des chiffres et des
lettres je te dis la vérité dans une
entreprise normale si un entretien
d'embauché en patron demande michel vous
êtes exceptionnel vous avez un comptable
en nombre vous avez d'excellentes
compétences mais est ce que vous vous
rentrez détruits et ben je vous
répondrai au tribunal la télé réalité
depuis la semaine dernière c'est ça du
tournage des anges aux on a été en
quasiment enterrée vivante en fait de là
on appelle le producteur ce que le
producteur était défoncée il ya il ya
une année une candidate qui un candidat
à gabat lancé deux sauts de javel au
visage
non oui et il ay là il était sur le
point lui balancer un sceau du rin
il faut savoir aussi qu il ne passe pas
au téléphone portable il ya là la drogue
heureusement les mecs ils n'en peuvent
plus l'histoire à l'hôtel ils vont
exploser des tas d'autres vous prendre
une giclée
joris d'une prostitution harcèlement
visiblement sert il s'est pris pour
bernard de la villardière
la vraie question qui nous taraude tout
ce qui produit cette émission alors moi
j'ai cherché et j'ai trouvé la réponse
regarder le diable les réalités la télé
réalité je voudrais revenir sur un sujet
mon chéri mais je vois pas qui d'autre
peut produire des trucs pareils mais je
voudrais surtout revenir sur un sujet
important l'immigration important on
parle toujours de ce qui arrive en
france surtout en ce moment mais il est
aussi le sujet des immigrés ceux qui
partent ce qu'on en voit à la télé et à
l'étranger et qui représente notre pays
et quand c'est thomas pesquet mois avec
cyril je dis oui regardez
[Musique]
alors quand c'est les marseillais je dis
non directionnelle si on avait envoyé de
ces gens là dans l'espace tous des gens
boivent de l'eau commençait des gens
droits
je préférais contre d'exporter des
fromages et du vin plutôt que des
influenceurs sur un autre sujet cyril je
dis tu as parlé du sujet de brahim
boullane et tu as posé cette question
cette histoire on en entend parler je
vous le dis depuis des jours et des
jours je vous dis même moi on m'a appelé
je vous dis on a appelé tout boum a
appelé aussi pour essayer de jeu puis
juin le roi du maroc pour lui demander
voilà si où ils étaient sept à terre si
on pouvait faire quelque chose alors la
question est ce que tu peux appeler le
roi du maroc cyril je vais te décevoir
c'est le mais la réponse est non
crois-moi cyril je connais le pays je
crois que le roi du maroc à 30 millions
d'autres priorités ils s'appellent les
marocains mais ceux qui ont raté la fin
de la semaine je vais essayer de résumer
en quelques secondes
bernard minet pour un navire une tête
d'arabe marion indien si vous avez
compris le contenu de ces extraits ou si
vous pigez quelque chose
peter de tpm paix c'est que vous êtes un
génie merci donc de contacter d'urgence
l'université d'harvard d' on à du très
lourd qui arrive la jolie l'emerging est
dur car il va rentrer dans un gobelet en
plastique des sentiers pour finir cyril
tous les jours tu lances des questions à
tout va et vendredi tu as répondu à la
question fondamentale que tous les
français se posent idéaux le kiki je
sais pas si vous avez vu cette info nous
si lille moi je voulais vous coupez
havrais vous couper ou chez jive cette
gt gt coupe à la naissance
le morceau est au père lachaise petite
île de cyril et au père lachaise
c'est ça que j'aime dans des pnb et
qu'on s'amusait qu'on est près des
interrogations des français
azéma porto
[Applaudissements]